j'ai été trop payés pas assez payés
c'est vraiment très très complexe qui
s'arrête jamais il ya toujours des
nouveaux problèmes qui se produit rubis
couture à des problèmes de paye depuis
à la suite d'un changement de ministère
selon son syndicat le gouvernement
serait prête à offrir une compensation
générale d'une journée écart de congés
payés par an pendant quatre ans aux
employés touchés par phoenix pour un
total de cinq jours une proposition qui
laisse ruby couture perplexe pour moi un
élément je pense que saint geours c'est
insultant c'est un manque de respect
envers nous et envers toutes les en plus
des jours de congés le gouvernement
propose des mécanismes de réclamations
pour des pertes financières liées à
phoenix l'alliance de la fonction
publique du canada qui représente la
majorité des employés fédéraux a rejeté
cette offre qu'elle qualifie de
dérisoire
nos gens sont insultés il préfère ne
rien avoir que d'avoir une journée pour
un médecin par année parce que cyril
plus qu'une insulte nos gens les cinq
jours de congés chiffre est maintenant
c'est loin d'être suffisant en plus que
sachez que phoenix est encore long pour
8 à 10 ans des syndicats ont accepté
l'entente cette entente la hausse pour
compenser les dommages intérêts des
dernières années on aurait pu opter pour
des paiements forfaitaires ou de
l'intérêt sauf que ce genre de paix mapa
serait justement par là système phoenix
et phoenix présentement est complètement
débordé de transaction c'est pour une
compensation très énorme mais dans la
situation où on est où on veut faire
avancer les choses
c'est en même temps de reconnaissance du
gouvernement du tort qu'ils ont eu
vis-à-vis les employés alors que
d'autres syndicats par contre préfèrent
se donner un peu de temps pour y
réfléchir
pour moi c'est vraiment important de
consulter les membres basque ils sont
les personnes qui souffrent pendant la
dernière cattin et pour moi c'est c'est
eux qui doivent décider si ce sujet que
nous attendons tous les syndicats
comptent poursuivre la lutte pour que
leurs membres tiennent une juste
rémunération
ce qui me fait encore plus de perdre sa
cage à ces convois vivre ça pour
facilement
5-1 même jusqu'à 12 ans ici florence
green au radio canada ottawa